I mean it was a classic Boris Johnson
speech completely deluded about what's
happened over the last couple of years
and the crisis that people are facing
High tax under the conservatives under
Boris Johnson the highest tax rate for
decades High inflation lower living
standards businesses that are facing
absolute bankruptcy because of the
situation on business rates do nothing
on that done nothing to support UK
industry and I just felt that there was
no acknowledgment of how the Scandal and
sleaze that has engulfed his party and
his government over the last couple of
years whether that was him supporting
the Scandal around Owen Patterson
supporting Chris pincher with the
situation with sexual harassment whether
that was the absolute billions of pounds
that was wasted on money that was given
to mates through the global pandemic and
of course the partying that happened
when the UK public were told that they
had to go into lockdown and had to
follow the rules I think it was
completely deluded and it stunk of all
the Hallmarks of somebody who's had a
privileged background who thinks that
they can just do what they like
I mean Angel Lauren you made that very
clear as to how you felt about him you
didn't actually answer my question
because now that he has gone after all
of those scandals that you're laid out
you've got this trust to face it was
already
perhaps got a proposal that goes Way
Beyond the labor price plan to deal with
the energy crisis that we're facing
well I've not seen any proposal that
goes beyond Labor's plan Labor's been
calling for a freeze on the energy bills
and that we've said it should be paid
for by a windfall tax on oil and gas
companies this trust hasn't said that
she thinks that working people should
foot the bill for that
um she said that she would reverse the
National Insurance contribution rise
which she voted for let's be clear Liz
truss has been part of the cabinet and
has been part of the decisions that have
been made that has propped up Boris
Johnson and got the country in the
message so now so yes it's great that
Boris Johnson has left anyone would
think that he's left of his own fruition
when that's clearing up true but we've
seen a conservative party that are
behind the curve constantly on the
crisis that is engulfing many people and
many businesses in the UK today and I
don't think they're in touch with what's
happening on the ground in the UK
they're completely deluded the GP
situation the NHS situation the social
care situation trying to get a passport
trying to get you driving license it's
complete backlog because of the
conservatives have not been doing their
job
yep and the reporting this morning Miss
Rainer is that some 100 billion pounds
is going to be spent and that would
bring in a freeze and energy bills and
the reporting in a conservative leading
newspapers suggests that's going to come
in until 2024. now as you know the labor
policy was 28 billion for only six
months so I'll put it to you again that
the conservatives have outflanked you on
this one
well no because we can't just quite
frankly keep pouring money in the
conservatives have raised the national
debt we've seen inflation at its highest
rate laborers said that we've got to
have a medium-term plan where we look at
Renewables we look at home insulation
and that we boost a long-term strategy
around how we deal with our energy
crisis the government have been in power
for 12 years and again Boris Johnson
talked about Jam tomorrow it was all
we're going to get these nuclear power
stations one every year that's tomorrow
not today there's been 12 years of
conservatives where they've failed to
deal with these issues and now we're at
a crisis point we do have to have a
long-term solution to this Labor's put
that plan forward and we can't just keep
going from one crisis to the next we
have to have a long-term plan from the
government about how we're going to use
Renewables and how we're going to
insulate homes and how we're going to
get these good skilled jobs into the UK
so that instead of leveling down which
is what we've seen Boris Johnson talked
about rail investment meant Northern
rail has been scaled down the people of
Greater Manchester the only reason we're
getting changes to transport is because
of our labor mayor in Greater Manchester
we're making a difference on the ground
the government have leveled down and
have not delivered on the promises that
they made to the people of the UK
and I thought on the potential makeup of
the of the top team of this dress is
putting in place it looks like it's
going to be one of the most diverse
great States office states of office um
in history with not one white man in
that grouping I mean as the labor party
who had the first black mp uh is it
shameful that the conservative party
beat is having such a diverse cabinet
well I welcome diversity in politics
I've been talking about that for a very
long time both on social economic but
also on ethnicity and of people from up
and down the UK being involved in
politics and I think it's important that
we do that but it's also important about
what people do and this trust has been
part of the cabinet that has got us into
this situation in the first place and
now we need to see action to make sure
that people of Britain can see real
change that will help them with their
living standards now this trust
throughout this leadership campaign has
not been talking about the issues that
are really facing the people of the UK
she's been talking about tax cuts as
opposed to really dealing with the cost
of living crisis that businesses and
households are facing at the moment so I
think it's more about what you do in
government that is really important at
the moment to people of the UK but
diversity is always welcome we need more
diversity in politics and in the
executive boardrooms in all of our UK
top companies
right and Angelina finally then you
would have heard in Boris Johnson speak
talked about literas being the leader of
the whole of the UK but you'll know that
there is of course that um independence
movement in Scotland and there is
reporting now that Liz trust is going to
bring in new legislation to try and make
it even more difficult for the SNP to to
go for Independence I mean
democratically how dangerous is that if
new legislation is going to come in I
know you perhaps don't support
Independence for Scotland but how
dangerous democratically is that new
legislation going to be for that
movement
I think one of the most dangerous things
that we've seen in the UK and it applies
to Scotland as well as parts of England
that feel left behind is the inequality
that's growing in in the UK and I think
that is the most dangerous risk to the
union at the moment is people need to
see that real investment not Jam
tomorrow not broken promises but
Investments across the United Kingdom
and that Devolution so that people have
more control over what's happening in
their lives locally and I think if we're
able to do that and people can see that
respect is given to all parts of the UK
and opportunities given then I think
that will solve some of these issues but
until that happens then of course people
are going to be frustrated just as
people in the north of England have been
frustrated I can see why people in
Scotland are frustrated and the only way
really we can change all of that is by
changing the government and having a
labor government that are willing to
invest in all parts of the UK